There're a number of advanced and open issues in analogical reasoning,
that are the subject for current research. First, because analogical reasoning
entails cross-domain transfer, does it mean that we necessarily need a common
vocabulary across all the domains? Consider the example of the atomic structure
and the solar system once again. Suppose I were to use this term revolve,
to say the electron revolves around the nucleus. But use the term rotate to say
the planet rotates in an orbit around the sun. I have used two different terms.
How then can I do alignment between these two situations? Should I use the same
vocabulary? If I don't use the same vocabulary, what alternative is there?
Second, analogical reasoning entails problem abstraction and transformation. So
far we have talked as if the problem remain fixed, it's source case is
retrieved and transferred across. But often, the agent needs to abstract and
transfer the problem, in order to be able to retrieve the source case.
A third issue in analogical reasoning concerns compound and
compositional analogies. So far we have talked that given a problem, we
can retrieve a case and transfer some knowledge from that case to the problem.
But often we retrieve not one case, and we transfer knowledge from not one case,
but from several cases. If you're designing a car, you might design the engine
binology to one vehicle and the chassis binology to some other vehicle. This
is an example of compound analogy. But how can we make compound analogy work?
In compositional analogy, analogy works at several levels of abstraction.
Supposing we were to make an analogy between your business organisation and
some other business organisation. We might make this compositional analogy,
first at the level of people. Next to the level of processes. Third of level of
the organisation as a whole. This is another example of compositional analogy,
where mapping at one level supports transfer to the next level. How do
we do compositional analogy in AI agents? Fourth, visuospatial analogies. So
far we have talked about analogies in which it transferred necessarily engages
causal knowledge. But a large number of analogies in which causality is at
most implicit. We'll consider these visuospatial analogies later in the class.
Fifth, conceptual combination. A powerful learning mechanism is learning a new
concept by combining parts of familiar concepts. Analogical reasoning is one
mechanism for conceptual combination. I have a one concept, [UNKNOWN] concept,
that of the atomic structure, another concept, the solution concept.
The concept of the solar system. I take some part of the solar system knowledge,
combine it with my concept of the atom to get a new concept of the atom.
If you're interested in any of these issues,
I invite you to join the PhD program in Computer Science.